herzlich willkommen in meiner welt
heute gibt es das zweite oster video ich
werde heute diesen osterkorb backen und
wehrt euch zeigen wie man den social
hinbekommt ich habe ein grundrezept für
euch dass ich nämlich aus hefeteig
gemacht aber natürlich kann sein falls
ihr eine andere form als ich benutzt
kann sein dass sie eben etwas mehr oder
etwas weniger teig benutzt deswegen gibt
es eher zum grundrezept für den hefeteig
und dann zeige ich euch schritt für
schritt wie man diesen schönen corp
herstellt ihr könnt dann natürlich auch
wieder eurer fantasie freien lauf lassen
könnten dekorieren und machen wir das
möchte und ich würde sagen wir legen
jetzt auch gleich los und ich zeige euch
jetzt einmal die zutaten ihr braucht ein
kilo mehl 2 160 gramm zucker einem halb
würfel hefe da könnte auch nur eine
nehmen aber ich nehme jetzt einen halb
zwei teelöffel salz 160 gramm butter die
habe ich jetzt in der mikrowelle ganz
leicht zu lassen damit sie eben flüssig
wird aber nicht heiß wird und ich habe
hier 400 milliliter milch und da kann es
auch sein dass ihr bis zu 500 milliliter
benötigt aber beginnt erstmal mit 400 es
kommt nämlich immer darauf an wie groß
die eier sind und je größer die eier
sind umso weniger milch brauchen wir
zuerst mal nehme ich jetzt die hefe und
so praktisch in die milch die milch ist
ganz leicht lauwarm die milch darf auch
nicht zu heiß sein also nicht heißer als
35 grad
oder besser sogar 30 grad denn ansonsten
gehen die hefe kulturen kaputt und wenn
die kaputt sind dann geht euer hefeteig
nicht mehr auf dann mache ich hier so
eine kleine mulde ins mehl und gebe
jetzt hier die hefe mischung rein
ich lasse jetzt nicht vorher aufgehen
ich lasse jetzt einfach mal ein hefeteig
länger gehen wenn ihr diese hefe
mischung auf gehen lasst dann müsste
etwas zucker mit dazu geben damit die
hefe sich vom zucker ernähren kann
und dann geht später ein gesamter teig
schneller auf da kommen jetzt einfach
alle zutaten reihen bis auf das feld des
fed dürfte aber erst zum schluss mit
rein geben wenn es schon etwas verkehrt
ist ansonsten schließen sich nämlich die
fettzellen um die hefezellen und die
gehen dann nicht mehr schön auf jetzt
lasse ich das schön mit der
küchenmaschine verkneten das könnte aber
natürlich auch mit der hand verkneten
und jetzt gebe ich hier noch das feld
mit dazu ich werde jetzt die
küchenmaschine wieder einschalten und da
müsste jetzt darauf achten dass der teig
nicht so trocken wird und wenn ihr merkt
er braucht etwas flüssigkeit gibt
einfach noch ein bisschen milch mit dazu
ich habe hier keine extremisten
zugegeben ihr könnt es jetzt hier mal
sehen
der teig ist aber jetzt schon immer noch
sei klebrig und ich werde ein teil jetzt
auch mindestens fünf minuten kneten
lassen wenn nicht sogar fast zehn
minuten damit er einfach eine richtig
schöne konsistenz hat schön elastisch
wird und ich werde hier sogar noch ein
bisschen mehl dazugeben müssen also bei
mir waren die 400 milliliter milch fast
schon zu viel
da müsste wirklich auf die eier größe
darauf aufpassen und die eier die ich
benutzt habe waren wirklich sehr groß
wer den tag dann lange genug geknetet
habt dann hat er seine konsistenz
erklärt dann auch nicht mehr an den
fingern
also ihr könnt es richtig gut sehen der
klebt dann nicht mehr sondern löst sich
hier auch ganz locker von den geräten
und dann könnte ihnen da auch rausnehmen
und dann gebe ich etwas mehl auf eine
arbeitsfläche nehmen dann den teig mit
zum 2 karte heraus und ich sehe das
jetzt auch schön der teig ist zwar weich
aber eben nicht mehr klebrig dann gebe
ich auch etwas mehl oder etwas fett in
meine schlüssel gibt den tag hinein und
bettdecke meine schüsse jetzt mit etwas
folie oder einem deckel und kann den
teig jetzt etwa eine halbe stunde bis
stunde an einem warmen ort gehen lassen
und auch da bitte darauf achten dass der
ort nicht über 30 grad hat bei mir ging
der teig etwa eine stunde auf und man
kann deutlich sehen er hat an volumen
zugenommen
und jetzt müsst ihr euch eben überlegen
was für eine form ihr benutzt um euren
korb zu flechten und da bieten sich
jetzt mehrere dinge an und zwar habe ich
hier so ein paar edelstahl schüsseln die
könnte man jetzt benutzen da hat nur
keine von der form her gut gefallen also
die hier fand ich zu flach da war mein
corp einfach zu kurz gewesen diese hier
fand ich eigentlich ganz schön aber mir
war es ja auch nicht hoch genug weil wir
müssen überlegen wenn ihr den korb
flechten und daran ist nicht hoch dann
sieht man ja fast nichts vom rand und
dann hat er den korb geflochten und man
sieht eigentlich gar nichts von ihm
diese hier wäre auch möglich aber ich
wollte einfach dass der rand eben auch
hier höher ist und ich hatte auch schon
überlegene porzellan form zu nehmen
zwar war dann zu riskant weil ich nicht
wusste ob sie dann beim abkühlen wieder
platzt
durch diesen temperaturunterschied im
ofen und mit der außentemperatur
da müsste einfach schauen was ihr dann
nehmen könnte und dann nicht mehr
eingefallen dass ich ja noch diese vor
mir habe und zwar ist es eine kuchenform
also eine backform als fußball und
eigentlich habe ich die mir bestellt
wegen der fußball-wm die dieses jahr
ansteht
und da wollt die dann erst in den shop
mit aufnehmen aber von der form her
passt die super weil sie hier schön hoch
ist schön eine halbkugel ist und da kann
man richtig tollen korbflechten und die
werde ich jetzt benutzen die verlinkte
ich euch dann auch in meiner infobox die
stelle ich dann jetzt schon in den shop
rein weil einfach falls es eben auch
jemand nachmachen möchte könnte die
benutzten oder wie gesagt könnt ihr euch
ein paar edelstahl formen nehmen
der vorteil von dieser form ist dass sie
eben antraf beschichtet ist das heißt
ihr könnt ihr einfach ein bisschen
einfetten und benutzen falls ihr eine
edelstahl form nimmt wie die anderen
müsste die mit alufolie begleiten und
dann auch noch mal einfetten
weil ihr sonst in teig von diesen formen
nicht abbekommt und bei dieser form ist
wirklich so d'isere kratzfest und die
ich auch so wirklich super toll wenn ihr
jetzt benutzt müsste die auch etwas
einfetten damit einfach später einfacher
geht den teig wegzunehmen
weil es ja einzelne teigschichten sind
und da wird man den eventuell
kaputtmachen wenn man den eben jetzt
nicht ein fettes machte setzten zu einem
flüssigen mit so einem bock spray tag
geht es nämlich sehr einfach kann ich
einfach einmal außen rum und das
einfetten bewirkt auch das datei jetzt
gleich wenn ich ihn darauf schlechte
einfach kleben bleibt und mir nicht
ständig am rand runter rutscht und
deswegen solltet ihr das eben auch
einfetten könnte auch ein ganz normale
ganz normale mutter benutzen und dann
ist es egal
so habe ich jetzt ein ei drin und etwas
milch das in etwa 50 milliliter milch
und es verrührt jetzt schon mal damit es
für später bereit ist als in dem werde
ich dann später meinen corp bestreichen
und es benutze ich auch als kleber falls
eben da zeigt man nicht geben sollte
könnte das einfach so verwenden
hier seht ihr jetzt diesen wunderschönen
teil und könnte ihn jetzt aus der form
herausnehmen und ich werde jetzt erstmal
nur die hälfte benutzen
jetzt müsst ihr euch überlegen wie hoch
ihre form ist und wieder durchmesser ist
und jetzt braucht ihr nämlich streifen
die ihr hier überlegen könnte und zwar
16 stück und da ich das aber so mache
dass ich sieben über die mitte darüber
läge mache ich jetzt nur acht lange
streifen legt sie hier drüber und es
zeige ich euch jetzt drückt den einfach
ein bisschen flach und bei ge verteilt
mich da auch keine angst haben sie da
was kaputt macht den kann man wirklich
gar nicht kaputt machen jetzt rollig den
mit nikolaus wahlstab aus und ihr seht
ich brauchte jetzt auch gar kein mehl da
klebt auch nichts dran
mit einem holz aus roller braucht ihr
etwas mehl und schönes rechteck formen
und das habe ich jetzt so etwa 5 mm dick
ausgerollt und jetzt nehme ich mir hier
meinen tag stäbchen es lebe ich ja
normalerweise um zu sehen wie dicke ich
was ausrollen muss und hier sieht man
auch das netz 5 mm dick und es benutze
ich jetzt aber als abstandshalter ich
möchte den letzten streifen einen
zentimeter dick ausrollen das könnte
entweder nach augenmaß machen
oder er benutzt euch ebenso was als
hilfe und schneidet da jetzt die teig
streifen
sie können jetzt entweder mit einem teig
rädchen schneiden
jetzt nehme ich mir das erste stückchen
hier und man sieht auch die sind so lang
und jetzt rolle ich die mir einfach in
so eine schöne gleichmäßige rolle
deswegen ist auch nicht schlimm wenn ihr
hier nicht gleichmäßig schneidet also
das soll einfach nur bewirken dass das
ungefähr gleichmäßige stücke sind jetzt
lege ich das erste stück hier einfach
über die mitte am rand hier unten darf
es ruhig wegschauen und dieses stück
nehme ich jetzt weg
das zweite lege ich jetzt hier im
rechten winkel drüber als ein kreuz
bilden
da kommt jetzt noch mal möglichen kreuz
drüber
da müsste jetzt eben schön schauen ich
habe jetzt hier acht stück also habe ich
jetzt 16 kleine stückchen hieraus
nahrung und da müsste auch darauf achten
dass es wirklich 16 sind denn dann
bekommt ihr richtig schönen corp falls
ihr sagt ihr möchtet lieber 16 einzelne
stücke machen würde ich euch davon
abraten
denn dann kann das hier passieren und
zwar dass ein stückchen dann nicht
zusammen hebt und dann habt ihr hier im
loch es hat sich nämlich beim ersten mal
so gemacht dass ich 16 einzelne gemacht
habe und beim backen sie dann hier
wieder runtergezogen und dann habe ich
jetzt hier eben leider dieses loch drin
ansonsten war der korb wirklich
wunderschön
nur eben dieses stück hier und deswegen
finde ich es besser wenn man das so
macht außerdem muss man dann nichts mehr
richtig fest drücken weil es hebt ja
dann alles von jeder seite sorgte sich
jetzt mal die grundstruktur und jetzt
kommen da die einzelnen schichten aus
das erste stück wegs in die hand und ihr
startet jetzt irgendwo einfach das erste
drunter also hier klickst runter und
dann lasst ihr diesen dieses stückchen
immer in der hand und jetzt müsst ihr
einmal drüber und einmal drunter das
heißt ich greife mit der anderen hand
wieder rüber tipps hoch und dass es
wieder runter dann geht's weiter hebt es
wieder hoch und runter als ihr seht hier
einmal drüber einmal drunter drüber
drunter also komplizierter drüber und
dann wieder runter
und dann kann ich das hier ab zwicken
und dass auch hier drunter verstecken
und schiebe ich mir das ein bisschen
hoch weil ich nicht möchte dass hier so
kleine löcher entstehen
dann nehme ich mir das nächste stück und
da weiß ich auch dass es jetzt nicht zu
lang sein muss es wird sogar mein mann
hinkriegen
jetzt starte ich nicht mehr an derselben
stelle sondern 1 versetzt das heißt
jetzt war es hier drüber
und jetzt muss ich hier drunter das tut
es auch kann
ich glaube dass die urlaub von allein
läuft
jetzt mache ich hier noch die letzte
reihe die krätscher unten jetzt noch
mithin nichts kann ich hier die strenge
abschneiden einfach bündig zum tisch ihr
seht ihr jetzt hier das hier auch löcher
drin sind das macht aber nichts
dabei geht jetzt gleich noch auf
wichtige schützt nur wenn er auch so
eine halbkugel habt wie ich dass ihr das
hier so ein bisschen flach drückt damit
der korb später ja auch dann eben flach
stehen kann
den gebe ich jetzt noch mal an den
warmen ort wieder nicht zu warm
ich lass einfach mein ofen auf 30 grad
und habe den dann ausgeschaltet und so
gebe ich dir jetzt nochmal rein für etwa
10 15 minuten
denn der ist schon ein bisschen
aufgegangen der teig und deutlich über
gleichmäßig aber das ist gar nicht
schlimm denn das ist ja anhand
geflochtener korb
den gebe ich jetzt rein und dann sehen
wir uns gleich wieder
während der korpus noch ein bisschen auf
geht habe ich jetzt hier schon mal ein
backpapier vorbereitet und zwar habe ich
da den durchmesser von der form vorhin
aufgezeichnet auf die rückseite mit
bleistift und die lege ich jetzt vor
mich hin und werd jetzt noch den kranz
flechten den ich dann obendrauf leben
möchte
und es zeigt sich hier einmal hier sieht
man den preis ganz leicht an gezeichnet
mit bleistift und den teig lebe ich
natürlich auf die rückseite damit man
eben keine bleistift rückstände im essen
hat das lege ich mir jetzt kurz auf die
seite und wird jetzt mit kranz flächen
wir außen rum geht um den späteren auf
den korb oben draufzulegen besitzt noch
der restliche tag den ich habe und ich
möchte jetzt daraus diesen kranz eben
foreman und den kranz könnte jetzt
entweder aus drei strängen flechten oder
ihr nehmt euch eben zwei stränge und
könnte zwirbeln ihr müsst aber bedenken
dass ja auch noch etwas von dem teig
braucht für den hängte deswegen werde
ich jetzt zwei stränge machen und diese
dann eben zwirbelt laster die einfach
irgendwo beginne und legt dann immer
dass andere drüber und das mache ich
jetzt direkt auf dem backpapier
und hier dienten könnte als einfach hier
schön verbinden
vor dem backen bestreite ich den korb
jetzt mit dieser eigelb mischung mit
dieser milch mischung einfach mit einem
silikon pinsel am besten die haare
nämlich nicht dadurch bekommt eben dann
einen schönen glanz und trocknet auch
nicht so schnell aus und bekommt auch
diese schöne farbe und sowie der
osterkorb jetzt bei etwa 160 grad ober
unterhitze so etwa 25 minuten gebacken
ist sollte sich auf jeden fall etwas
weiter unten in den ofen schieben also
eher im unteren drittel oder sogar
vierter
weil ansonsten die oberfläche zu schnell
braun wird also lieber ein bisschen
weiter unten und eben nicht so eine hohe
temperatur so sieht es der fertig
gebackene osterkorb aus ich halte jetzt
einfach mal hier drüber
jetzt könnte das sehen ich muss ihnen
ein bisschen kleiner machen also diesen
kranz damit er nicht so arg nach draußen
schaut und dann passt es auf jeden fall
nicht einfach hier drauf und ich lasse
jetzt auch eine zeit lang auf diesem auf
dieser form abkühlen damit einfach nicht
in sich zusammenfällt wenn der charakter
abgekühlt ist könnt ihr die form
darunter entfernen und dazu müsste das
hier nur ein bisschen lösen
am besten mit einer palette oder einem
nichts scharfen gegenstand
denn ansonsten bleibt euch das hier
hängen und dann macht euren corp
vielleicht kaputt
jetzt könnt ihr suchen ganz vorsichtig
den korb anzuheben
so habt ihr echt so ein bisschen geduld
und schüttelt ist vielleicht auch mal
dass sich das schön löst wird es
natürlich mit so einer alufolie form
gemacht habt geht es natürlich einfacher
und dann irgendwann sollte sich die form
davon lösen
den gebe ich jetzt einfach noch mal hier
drauf zum vollständigen abkühlen und
kann ihn zur seite stellen
auch der letzte teil meines körpers und
zwar der henkel und dafür habe ich mir
die reste jetzt in drei gleich große
kugeln geformt habe ich die drei teile
also den restlichen tag einfach
aufgeteilt habe die kugel nochmal gehen
lassen dann messen lassen sie sich viel
einfacher formen und jetzt nehme ich
wieder meine fußball form für eben den
henkel um das eben darauf zu formen und
fettet den jetzt natürlich wieder ein
und am besten findet ihr euch immer auch
mal die arbeitsfläche dann kann man die
viel besser hier drauf ausrollen
weil sie dann einfach nicht so hin und
herrutschen jetzt warum ich hier drei
stränge aus diesen drei kugeln beachtet
ihr bitte darauf dass sie nicht zu dick
sind sonst habt ihr einen dicken henkel
später so jetzt starten wir einfach hier
ganz normal wie beim zapfen flechten und
schlägen das rechte drüber dann das
linke in die mitte und am besten geht es
natürlich wenn ihr euch das in die hand
nimmt und dann könnt ihr den ganz
einfach unter schlechten jetzt nehme ich
die fußball form und schlägt den zopf
mit der schönsten stelle natürlich hier
drüber und ihr könnt den henkel jetzt
theoretisch auch länger machen indem ihr
die form auf eine andere form drauf
stellt und das so erhöht aber mir reicht
es so von der länge her das stück hier
unten kann weg jetzt könnte er auch
gestrichen werden und geht dann auch in
den backofen meine teile sind jetzt
gebackene und ich habe jetzt hier den
korb dann diesen henkel und eben diesen
kranz ich hab das jetzt alles einfach
schön abkühlen lassen und werde jetzt
nur noch die sachen zusammenfügen und
damit das alles eben schön kleben bleibt
also damit der kann sich hier drauf
bleibt und später der henkel eben auf
dem korb muss das ganze jetzt geklebt
werden und dafür werde ich jetzt ein
gräuel icing machen
mit etwas puderzucker etwas wasser
und eiweißpulver das eiweißpulver
verlinke ich euch in einer infobox es
gibt es in meinem shop mir kein eiweiß
bund war da habt oder eben das mit hohen
eiweiß machen wollt könnt ihr das auch
machen aber ich finde dieses
eiweißpulver kann man einfach besser
dosieren und man hat dann einfach kein
rohes ei weiß mit drin und wir brauchen
jetzt keine grosse menge deswegen nehme
ich jetzt nur 60 gramm puderzucker einen
gestrichenen esslöffel von diesem
eiweißpulver und wenn ihr kein
eiweißpulver happel mit eiweiß arbeitet
dann verkehrt er weiß ein bisschen und
nehmt etwa einen esslöffel davor aus
deswegen ist es immer besser mit diesem
prüfer weil man es einfach schön
dosieren kann jetzt gebe ich erst mal
nur einen halben esslöffel wasser mit
dazu das war nämlich eine feste
konsistenz haben nicht so flüssig und
wasser können da immer wieder dazu geben
und ihr seht ist jetzt auch das ist eine
richtig feste konsistenz
schaut mal dass tropft auch nicht gleich
runter das soll nämlich gleich richtig
schön kleben nicht verlaufen
und jetzt arbeite ich mit einer kleinen
palette so kann ich nämlich schön diese
creme immer neben und hier am rand
verteilen und für die männer unter uns
dass ich eigentlich nichts anderes als
mörtel sowie beim mauern streichen wir
jetzt diese mittel masse drauf und jetzt
leben wir diesen ring drauf und wenn ihr
da jetzt etwas überschuss habt könnt ihr
das einfach mit einem küchentuch etwas
wegnehmen zu müssen überlegen wo ihr den
hängt jetzt an bringen wollt an welcher
position
und jetzt nehme ich mir zahnstocher und
werdet es damit fixieren es würde auch
so halten aber damit einfach fest so
wird das könnt ihr dann selbst
entscheiden ob er das ernst stocker
nehmen oder schaschlikspieß oder ob es
bei euch auch vielleicht ohne helm und
die steche ich jetzt hier rein
ich habe jetzt hier etwas zucker klausur
unsere sieht jetzt der fertige korb aus
wir werden den jetzt natürlich nicht so
nackt und schwer lassen sondern werden
ihnen jetzt noch füllen
dafür habe ich jetzt ein paar
geschenkbänder ich hab ja da
ich habe ein bisschen oster gras da
können auch servietten alles mögliche
nehmen und dem korb einfach füllen ihr
könnt da zum beispiel auch etwas
gebackenes hineinfühlen
und wir machen es mal zusammen und
zeigen euch das jetzt
und so sieht jetzt unser fertiger
osterkorb aus wir haben dir jetzt schön
gefüllt mit samira paar wollte zog ihn
ihr einstecken
die weiter weg und da könnt ihr wie
gesagt alles mögliche reihen füllen und
wir werden das sieht amiras oben und opa
schenken hat sie schon gesagt das hat
sie für oma und opa gemacht da dürfen
die ein paar gekochte eier essen und
diesen osterkorb habe ich übrigens auch
mal im internet schon gesehen und zwar
an der bloggerin namens märz gegen
partys hat diesen osterkorb auch gemacht
ist sie hat ein bisschen ein anderes
rezept dafür danke ich euch auch mal den
block sie hat nämlich direkt unter meine
fragen gepostet dass sie das auch schon
gemacht hatte habe ich gleich drauf
geschaut werden richtig wunderschönen
corp hinbekommen da müsst ihr auf jeden
fall auch mal vorbeischauen
ich werde euch natürlich dieses rezept
auch in schriftform noch auf meinem blog
veröffentlichen
und ich freue mich wenn ihr natürlich
dieses konzept noch nach macht freue
mich über eure oster aber vielleicht
probiert da ein oder andere mal aus und
ich wünsche euch auf jeden fall noch
einen ganz schönen tag wenn euch das
video gefallen hat könnt ihr das gerne
teilen da freuen wir uns und wir sehen
uns beim nächsten mal wieder fußball